my name is Patricia and today we are
going to explore live kubernetes hacking
together so get ready for ride
first a brief introduction
I've been doing professional software
development for over 20 years yep
sometimes I do feel like a vintage
dinosaur
but hey who doesn't love a classic
I've always been close to code and that
Bond still arrives today
however almost two years ago I've joined
the Dark Side of platform engineering at
form three
and guess what
I absolutely loved it
today I'm a lead SRE engineer
so what do we do at form three
in short form free is a financial cloud
we provide a payment as a platform model
for quick and easy integration with
various payment schemes via rest API
we are technology oriented poly remote
cloud-based with microservices
architectures
we treat our infrastructure as code
almost religiously terraforming
everything possible
lately we are building a new multi-cloud
payment platform based on kubernetes and
free clouds
so obviously kubernetes kubernetes
security is super important to us
what am I going to talk about today
just a splash of theory in the ocean of
practice
the key part of today's talk features
two demos to hijack your accounts
exploiting various security issues in
auburnities application as well as in
cluster
but before the fun begins
let's do a quick review of the
kubernetes architecture
there's two main Concepts in kubernetes
the control plane and worker nodes
the control plane
basically manages the entire cluster
the heart here is an API server and when
we want to create or update any
kubernetes resource we need to
communicate with that server
it exposes a kubernetes HTTP API
that way we can interact with the
cluster using tools like Cube CTL and
who doesn't know Cube CTL
worker nodes are the place where the
real work happens
the actual ports run over there
cubelet is a main component
responsible for instantiation and
execution of pods
and like the API server cubelet also
exposes a rest API
but it's only like internal API however
sneak peek
we will exploit an unsecured cubelet API
to gain unauthorized access to the
cluster
what are the kind of security issues can
we see in our case clusters
it
oops sorry
[Applause]
yeah hopefully it won't happen again but
you never know fingers crossed
and we were just at our slide
so
nope it's not gonna work that way
um
okay so it's time to dive into our top
10 security list list so here always
basically stands for open web
application security project
I'm pretty sure that all of you know
what oasp is
basically the
they aim to raise and increase security
awareness among developers
so they published those top 10 security
lists every couple of years for various
Technologies and last year for the very
first time they published kubernetes top
10 security list so it's like a Hit
Parade where we can see what
vulnerabilities are the most important
or and the most popular
so um let's see the chart Toppers number
one insecure workload configuration so
basically here
watch out for root users for privilege
mode or writable file systems number two
supply chain vulnerabilities
here you need to keep an eye on how you
build package and distribute your
kubernetes applications
number three don't be to the generals
with your rpac permissions because
otherwise you will end up in a cluster
where everyone can be
let in
so number four basically a good piece of
advice is to centralize your policies in
a way that you reject any misconfigured
magnetic resources number five
if you don't watch your logs basically
you are like a security guard who fell
asleep on the job
then number six broken authentication
mechanism basically you need to
configure your authentication in a way
that doesn't allow anyone into the
cluster only
the users who have permissions
number seven with kubernetes flat
network security model we have a problem
because basically each workload can
communicate with each other so it's like
a house with all the doors wide open
what can we do basically we need to lock
them up
number eight Secrets management failures
as simple as that protect your secrets
uh by the way a colleague of mine Morris
is having a talk on external Secrets
operator later today
so don't miss that one it's gonna be a
blast
number nine
configure your configure and secure your
kubernetes components properly or
otherwise you will end up with a massive
barnetti's sample
and last but not least
keep your kubernetes components as well
as your workload up to date
because otherwise you might end up with
a bunch of uninvited guests in your
class term
so that's it when it comes to Theory
let's move to practice
and it's gonna be like one-on-one course
in kubernetes hacking but hopefully you
will get the feel of danger and you will
see how a series of simple
misconfigurations
can lead to a total compromise of the
entire system
here I will need your help
I have this vulnerable kubernetes
application prepared it's available on
the
cubecon.younglabs.com link
the link is available in the slide as
well as as in my Twitter account so
please register new account log in and
wait to be hacked
my objective here is to hack your
account and learn your secrets
so let the fun begin
you can see my Twitter account you can
see the link available here if you were
not able to scan it from the QR code
let's see how my application looks like
so once you log in you can see your
secret you can update your secret and
you can see active users
so all so many of you thank you for your
cooperation
so
once we see that we have so many users
waiting to be hacked let's move on
to my evil server
so basically I will log in to my Evo
server that's the server from which I
will do all hacking
This Server is in the same subnet as
Mike bonetti's cluster that's important
because uh
I'm gonna Target open cubelet API so the
first thing usually hackers though is
some sort of return sounds
usually in the form of like Port
scanning using tools like nmap net card
or something like that here we are
targeting cubelet API so we will use a
dedicated tool for this one basically we
will use qblock CTL
Cube CTL is a tool implemented by cyber
Arc that's a cyber security company and
it's similar to cube CTL so basically
here we have a wrapper around you blood
API
we also have the scan command I will use
the scan command
the sky to scan my Subnet for open
cubelet API
I will use like quite small side range
only slash 24y because I don't want to
take it too long
let's see what we have here okay yes as
expecting because I did it so yeah we
have open cubelet API what a surprise
what can we do with this one basically
with rest API we can just use car and
see what's going on here
let's see that one
we have for a form not found what
happened we don't have an end point on
this path let's use paths and point
okay we have something here let's use JQ
and it looks much better but it's not
very leadable so let's search for items
with meta data
and name that's gonna give us like
the names of of all the containers
running from a given node
okay we got it nice
so we see what containers run on on this
note what can we do else
we can still use Cube cubelet CTL and
scan command let's see help for this one
we have two sub commands available we
have RSC and token those are used the
first one is used to scan nodes for uh
for pods with remote code execution so
basically all the ports that allow to
execute any commands inside
and another one is token command and it
scans for all the tokens in a given node
so we're going for RCV rce1
let's do cubeletal scan rce and we are
targeting our server
yeah thank you
you are very vigilant
but and then I am on the stage
um okay so what we have here
we have a couple of parts that have RSC
rce available Calico note that's a
default installation of calicon
we have demo web server and we have demo
sad about them I like backend here okay
so that's most likely the ports we are
interested in were our demo demo
application is running now
okay so let's try
to run some command
inside the spot
so the port is here
the namespace is backhand and the
contain another type or sorry for this
one I'm too stressed it seems
okay and server is not
so let's run yep we are root over there
that's very nice
uh so what can we do now usually when
you are a hacker and you see that you
have like a remote comment execution
then the next step is pretty simple
establish a reverse shell what is a
reversal and basically if you want to
access remote server from a client
machine usually you SSH from a client
machine to a remote server you provide
provide your credentials basically you
log in and you are given a shout
reversal goes the other way around so
basically a server connects to a client
machine this way by passing uh
authentication step
so let's do reversial then
to Dollar reverse shell I need a second
session I need to log into my evil
server
and I need net card usually you
establish a reverse shells with net card
and you need one point that listens
so I will open listener on my
evil server and then I will
uh
establish execute basically a command
Inside My Demo server pod to connect
at to my Evo server
um that's an IP
4444 port and then I want to execute
shell
okay give me a let's give it a try yes
we have a connection we are in
that was nice and quick
so we are inside a port we are we have a
shell so what can we do now basically
again sniff around do summer Corner
sounds and see what else can we do to do
more harm
so usually we check for Yahoo am I we
know that we are raw that's perfect
let's see Mount unfortunately we are not
running in privileged mode we don't have
access to the host file system
however let's see if we have like
writable file system here
yes we have so basically when we have a
writable Pi system we can install
whatever you want if we have access to
the internet
uh but what else we can
take a look at let's do net start and
see what's going on on the spot
we see that the spot is listening on
1990 Port that's nice it would be good
to sniff the traffic
to sniff the traffic we need to have
like TCP dump do we have it let's see
I'm sorry I'm trying to do a redirect
here why redirect because this reverse
shell is not fully interactive shell so
it doesn't show me the error Stream So I
did a redirect to see any errors we
don't have TCP dump but we are Road
possibly we have apk here so and let's
add TCP dump
and okay so now we have TCP dump ready
so let's see if
our traffic
uh oops sorry
uh here on Port 99 and now I will need
your Hub could you please refresh your
pages after logging in yeah thank you it
happened even
yeah before I managed to say anything
okay too many daytime let's stop it and
let's
search for something interesting like a
better token
okay we have a better token now so what
can we do with a better token now it's
simple we just go to our
demo application and we replace my valid
token with one of yours let's refresh
the page and I'm very very ferriero
congratulations for Euro you've been
hacked
[Applause]
um okay so that's it for the first demo
what problems do we see here obviously
open cubelet API let's take a look at uh
official kubernetes documentation what
do we see here we see that Anonymous of
has the default true also authorization
mode has a default always allow
we could do better here however it's not
that bad because those are the defaults
for like raw plane kubernetes
installation usually we use manage
kubernetes like in Cloud eks gke AKs
whatever you imagine and those have
sensible defaults also if you use such
installation tools like Cube ADM you are
good they have again sensible security
defaults however if you install
your kubernetes clusters by head you can
end up with cubelet API fully open
so basically open cubelet API is like K9
from our OS top 10 list misconfigured
cluster components another issues we see
is like writable file system in your
container in that case you can see that
basically hackers can install or modify
can install anything or modify the code
of your application
so definitely use only a read-only file
systems another thing is running as Road
as road we have like
super privilege we are super user we can
do almost anything
is that in containers in in that
container we observed quite a few tools
available
so that's definitely not recommended
it's better to use this Rolex images
however remember that it doesn't
guarantee like a 100 security
there is that blog post from that team
lead of offensive security at form free
who explains all the corner cases of
destroyless images
another thing is not working
you know I've been doing this
professional software development for
over 25 years actually and I not able to
count how many times I had this
discussion with less experienced
developers about unencrypted traffic
inside internal Network
so it is countless and always the
arguments are the same like oh come on
it's on the internal network no one can
sniff it oh come on it's all about
performance
at the moment it's all about security if
you want to be secure basically encrypt
your traffic even inside your private
Networks
another thing is open egress to internet
once you have
this outbound traffic to the internet
open you are also open to many external
effects or once the hackers get in they
can download anything what's uh what
they can imagine
so basically
by keeping those very simple
uh measure security measures in your
deployment configuration you can improve
the overall security of your kubernetes
workloads and that's not a rocket
science
okay now it's time for our second demo
with our second demo
I will still use this application
how
uh however
I will also use another one another one
which is like a simple
hello application it says hello Patricia
in that case
however it also has like rce remote code
execution available so to hijack your
accounts in our demo application I will
use this vulnerable rce hello
application basically to access
the port and the workload in the same
kubernetes cluster
so let's see how it works okay you see
that who am I is www data usually it
means that Apache httpd server
underneath because that's the default
user for Apache
and what can we do here basically I'm
like a one trick pony again I'm gonna
use a reverse shell
but before I go to my reversal I have
one
uh
one asked to you if you could log out
and log in again
why I will explain that later
so please log out log in again and I
will start my hacking then
okay
I'm in my
evil server again
opening a listener
listening with netcut on this
44444 port and here I have
this NC
with Bash
available let me oh nope that's not the
right IP
sorry for this one too many attempts in
the past I think that's the one IP I
need to provide the correct IP of my
evil server
okay we are in
uh we are in let's take a look what's
going on here again who am i w w data uh
what about moms Oh What A pity we are
not road because we are we have the spot
running in a privilege mode
uh however as we are not ruled I'm not
gonna go this path I'm gonna go another
path let's just scan
our kubernetes subnet and see what's
listening
over there
here to avoid and save your time I have
some
cheat sheet available so basically I'm
gonna scan only
one IP and a given Port range
let's do this one
and let's do our scanning we see that we
have this free
6379 Port open what does it mean
basically in this port is a default port
for redis
so let's try that one
and see some and send some redis
commands here again I have this cheat
sheet available basically ready
Server doesn't support rest API they
support rasp protocol that's where this
serialization protocol why usually
because they sent a lot of data so to
save time
on serialization and the serialization
with Json and they've came up with this
specific protocol here
so I'm sending
ping command yeah we have Punk so
basically we have access to redis let's
see what is stored in the strategies
cluster
uh oh my God it looks like JWT tokens
again what a surprise
um okay let's grab one of the tokens
okay let's grab this one but first
before we grab it let's delete it
so
let's delete it okay it's deleted
um
but I'm
I need this token because I'm gonna use
it again
in our demo application maybe maybe
that's gonna be successful and again I
will hijack some of your accounts
so let's replace it
let's refresh
camish you've been hacked Thomas I think
you are polish as me
nice to
see you here and happy that you've been
hacked
so what happened here
we had
remote code execution in one kubernetes
deployment and this deployment is
running in the same cluster as our
Target application
so you can see how one vulnerable
workload can impact another workloads in
the same cluster so basically that came
10 from the OAS top 10 list outdated and
vulnerable components also another thing
we exploited is missing Network
segmentation
basically from this rce
hello application pod we could connect
to read this cluster in another
namespace dedicated for another
application so that's like missing
Network segmentation controls K7 from
the OAS top 10 list again quite a few
tools available reverse fell possible
and one big No-No Anonymous access to
radius obviously you shouldn't have any
Anonymous accesses to any data store or
workload your um in your clusters
um
so let's sum up what we've learned today
I can only tell you that's like the tip
of the iceberg when it comes to
kubernetes security
so I could go on and on about the topic
but fortunately on unfortunately or
perhaps fortunately for you we are
running out of time so only some final
remarks here
you should remember about the Swiss
cheese security model basically this
model
illustrates the importance of layered
security
uh
like stacking swiss cheese slices
you have those
multiple layers multiple overlapping
layers of your security mechanism and
controls and
basically
this way you can cover
that holes or weaknesses of other layers
so you are only vulnerable if all those
holes are aligned in the same line
so basically instead of relying on a
single security mechanism you need to
implement defense in that layer security
and your ultimate goal is not to have
like a perfect solution because that's
impossible when it comes to security the
goal is to
um
to make the life of bad guys more
difficult and to help us good guys
to detect and respond to any potential
security threats
remember that a fool with a tool is only
a full so
don't be fools
use your tools wisely use your
kubernetes wisely
and here we have in software development
we have different paradigms like
continuous integration
continuous deployment some talk about
continuous refactoring
but the fundamental Paradigm is
continuous learning
so we as devops should keep educating
ourselves
thank you and thank you for your
cooperation